collectivement pour freiner le
réchauffement de la planète?
Jacaudrey Charbonneau a posé la
question à plusieurs citoyens.
Jacaudrey Charbonneau
a posé la question
à plusieurs citoyens.
- Toutes nos ventes
sont axées vers les VUS.
- Chez ce concessionnaire
Mitsubishi de Boucherville,
on ne vend pratiquement
plus de voitures.
DANY LEMELIN, président,
Boucherville Mitsubishi
- Les gens, la plupart,
veulent tous un VUS. On a juste
à regarder sur nos routes.
- L'espace, le chargement,
le camping, la famille,
le sport, la sécurité;
beaucoup de raisons poussent
les consommateurs à acheter
de plus gros véhicules.
- Le côté pratique, t'sais,
le fait qu'on peut juste,
souvent, les familles, se payer
un véhicule qui est capable
de faire à peu près tout.
T'sais, avec deux sièges
d'enfant à l'arrière, tu peux
pas nécessairement fonctionner
avec une "subcompact".
- Même si ce sont beaucoup
des petits véhicules utilitaires
sport qui sont populaires,
l'impact sur les émissions
de CO2 n'est pas négligeable.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAULT,
prof. titulaire, HEC Montréal
- C'est vrai que les petits VUS
ou même les plus gros VUS,
ils ont fait des grosses
améliorations en termes
de consommation d'essence.
Le problème, c'est
qu'on devrait consommer moins.
- Pourtant, l'environnement est
au coeur des préoccupations.
L'environnement, c'est un enjeu
qui vous touche beaucoup?
- Exactement, exactement.
Écoutez, regardez,
il fait chaud aujourd'hui,
on est à la fin d'août.
- Mais surtout l'environnement,
en première place.
- Puis votre véhicule,
vous l'avez choisi comment?
(rire)
- Parce que c'est un Dodge Ram.
Ah! C'est pour le camping.
J'ai une roulotte,
on tire la roulotte avec.
- C'est l'enjeu prioritaire
de la campagne, selon les
utilisateurs de la Boussole
électorale de Radio-Canada.
FANNY TREMBLAY-RACICOT, prof.
Admin. municipale et rég., ENAP
- Il y a une certaine
contradiction, je pense
que ça fait partie
de la nature humaine.
Mais le gouvernement fédéral
a toute la légitimité
pour intervenir en matière
de changements climatiques.
- Et il faut s'attaquer
au secteur du transport,
un des plus polluants
au Canada et au Québec
et qui est en croissance.
- Ça, ce sont des choix
de consommation. Ce sont
des choix qui sont conditionnés,
puis qui sont conditionnés
notamment par le prix.
Puis le gouvernement fédéral
a une taxe d'accise sur
les véhicules énergivores,
mais cette taxe-là, elle est
largement inefficace.
- En 2019, ils étaient
des centaines de milliers
à demander plus d'actions
pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques.
Albert Lalonde était
parmi les organisateurs
de la mobilisation.
ALBERT LALONDE, militant
- Je pense qu'on n'a pas
le choix de continuer.
Le cynisme, c'est pas un luxe
qu'on a. L'urgence climatique
est toujours aussi actuelle.
- Malgré une pandémie et
une mobilisation moins visible,
il milite toujours,
même s'il croit qu'aucun
parti politique ne va assez loin
pour la planète.
- Les gens veulent de l'action
en environnement, savent pas
exactement ce que ça implique,
mais ils en veulent.
Je pense aussi qu'il y a
très, très peu d'initiatives
de la part des gouvernements
pour vraiment mettre en lumière
les solutions.
- Parce que devant
un problème si vaste,
il faut du courage politique,
selon Pierre-Olivier Pineau.
- Les partis sont très limités
dans les propositions agressives
et efficaces qu'ils pourraient
mettre de l'avant
parce que ces propositions, pour
qu'elles fonctionnent vraiment,
devraient forcément impliquer
une contrainte ou une limite
ou un frais supplémentaire,
et ça, ça passe très mal
dans l'électorat.
- Ce qui est important, c'est de
mettre en oeuvre des mesures qui
vont avoir de véritables impacts
sur les choix, donc les
pratiques des individus.
- Un exercice délicat pour
les partis politiques.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, M